warriors and hunters Wizards and priests
long now have your four classes lived
together as one and how they have
flourished where once stood only a few
Marriott's now looms a glorious city of
iron and steel trade and commerce music
and laughter a place called ardent I've
been watching you these many years have
seen the sparks from your anvils fly
have observed your gardens blossom and
your life stalks well I've heard the
spinning of your ever busy looms and
have listened to the craft of mighty
timber fell your bountiful villages have
multiplied as have the feats of your
brain arrows men and women who have
valiantly explore terrifying and
wondrous new lands together new have
battled ghoulish fiends and defeated
nightmarish beasts several of which were
the very last of the relics of Horrors
I'm afraid though that not quite all of
Malik's clan has been extinguished I
know of one member who was patiently
abided his time deep within a fortress
of stone
Shane you not hear it of course you
can't vanity and self-indulgence are
sure they dialed your senses so put down
your pies and ales and listen now that
is the sound of true unity the gates the
castle Tyrell have been flung wide and a
thousand soldiers cut from unbreakable
stone March forth they have been given
one directive to crush ardent just as
your for elders through my master when
he was at the height of his power so to
where I destroy your glorious City and
all those who helped to build it how
ignorant you all are to think that I
would have let the death of Malik go
unpunished or that I have merely sat
idly by these many years
you need only venture inside my
impenetrable mountain to find that I
rule an entire kingdom old beasts you
thought long dead I found a home with me
while new creatures are daily forged
from the heart of the mountain I have
been amassing an army for decades and
now at last my avalanche of stone has
been released
all will be crushed patrons
I am Lord
Pyrus